Good morning, everyone. It is 10:00
on Tuesday, May 17. Welcome. This is
a continuation of the Budget and Fiscal Affairs Committee meetings and budget
presentations from various departments in the city of Houston. I'll call this
meeting to order and like to welcome all council members in attendance.
Council Member Tasha Jackson district B council Member Abby Cayman
district C council Member Tiffany vice
Chair Edward J. Pollard District J staff from Council
member Michael Kubosh's office michael Knox martha Castex
tatum carlos Cisneros and Amy
Peck and Tiffany Thomas thank you.
And staff from Council Member Alcorn's office and plumber.
All budget workshops would be conducted in person. Only public speakers
have the option to comment in person or virtually
48 hours prior to the start of all workshops. All presentation materials
are uploaded to SharePoint and hard copies are delivered to each
council office. All departments have been directed to provide written
responses within 48 hours of the conclusion of their presentation
to any questions posted by council members to SharePoint budget
workshop is scheduled. Schedule is posted on the BFA
website. Questions from council members can be uploaded at any time
during the budget workshop process, the earlier the better,
allowing the departments plenty of time to respond to questions.
All public speakers should be signed up to speak. If you have
not signed up, please sign up at the front table
facing our left. Your right.
Budget 23 template has been uploaded
to SharePoint. And Mayor Turner, as we know, sent out a memo to
all council members and offices to ensure productive discussions on
the proposed budget. And all amendments are due Wednesday,
May 25. Today we'll hear from
General Services Department. Promptly on time, as always.
Parks and Recreation and the Houston Police Department.
As a reminder, only people attending virtually are the public speakers.
We'll get to their questions after the presentations and after questions from
council members have concluded. At this time,
I would like to welcome Director CJ Messiah and Mr. Russell Lee to
provide the General Services Department budget.
Thank you and welcome. And I see you have your department members with
us. You all do a great job day in and day out, so thank you
for what you do. Except you,
Eric. That's my man.
All right.
Can you hear me? All right. There it is. Good morning and thank
you for the opportunity to present the fiscal year 2023 budget for
the General Services Department. I have three principles that I
share with our GSD team, and that's integrity. First, service before self
and excellence in all we do.
With me today is my senior staff, which includes
Chief of Staff Enid Howard. Assistant Director
of Design and Construction and Real Estate, Richard Veylor.
Assistant Director of Property Management, Eric Alexander.
Deputy Assistant Director of Security Management, Robert Mansaw.
Our training division manager, Darnisha Davis Collier
my Executive assistant, Levanda Donohue senior
Staff Analyst, Shelley Carter, who manages the energy Resilience
and efficiency program and to my right, a Chief Financial
Officer and Division Manager, Russell Lee, who will be assisting me in answering any
financial questions regarding the fiscal year 23 proposed
budget. Next slide.
GSD operations are divided into four core programs
of service one, property and environmental management
two, design and construction and real estate services three
security management and four, administrative,
financial and energy management services with the primary goals
of reducing costs and continuing to improve our level of customer
service. Our current organizational structure
shows our total operating budget for the General Fund to
be just over $42.1 million with 154
FTEs. Next slide.
The project cost recovery fund has a proposed budget of
$6.8 million with 51 FTEs.
All expenses in this fund are charged back to the Capital Improvement
Plan or CIP, Bond funds. The FTEs
in this fund provide CIP planning,
management, manage the design and construction facilities
for all departments except the Houston Airport System, manage the
CIP construction contracts, and facilitate tenant moves
and improvements. By mid September this year,
we will be complete with the A leaf neighborhood center and the maintenance
and operational costs are included in our FY 2023
proposed budget. Next slide.
The Maintenance, Renewal and Replacement, or MRR
fund has a proposed budget of $30.77
million and 76 FTEs.
This fund provides for the maintenance, repair and replacement of building
systems and operational components for mechanical,
electrical, plumbing, HVAC, life, safety, security,
monitoring, structural and energy systems.
Next, in our
General Fund revenue budget, there's an increase of $29,000
due to an escalations on rents that GSD collects and
an increase of $19,000 due to an increase in planned
projects that will be charged back to the Fleet Department and
Parking Management. General Services will continue
to charge back its personnel costs for operations of public works
facilities. There is a decrease in miscellaneous revenue
as we do not budget for possible recoveries and refunds.
Next.
Our General Fund revenue is budgeted at 3.9 million
with changes as discussed in the previous slide. Our Project
Recovery Fund revenue is budgeted at just under $6.8
million, an increase of $1.6 million due
to the hiring of additional project managers and support
personnel. During fiscal year 22, our in
house renovation group budget was decreased to zero due to this
group being dissolved and FTEs being moved to the General Fund
or MRR. Fund. Our MRR revenue
is budgeted at $29.8 million, which is the same
as the FY 22 adopted budget.
The increase over fiscal year 21 is primarily due
to finance reducing the revenue transferred into the Fund in
FY 21 to assist with the FY 21
budget deficit. Next slide.
For FY 23, we are proposing an expenditure budget
in our General Fund of $42.2 million. The restricted
accounts include service chargeback accounts for items such as
fuel, electricity, It accounts, et cetera.
Next slide.
The total proposed budget for all funds for fiscal
year 2023 is $79.6 million.
Next slide.
In the General Fund, the $28.3 million
nonpersonal costs make up roughly 67% of the
General Fund budget. Restricted accounts represent
roughly 38% of the total nonpersonal
costs. The remaining nonpersonal budget is for services such
as janitorial services, security management,
sewer services, real estate rentals and landscaping.
Next, the Project
Cost Recovery Fund personnel costs make up 97%
of the budget, with restricted accounts and miscellaneous services making
up the remaining 3%.
Next,
in the MRR Fund, the $23.7 million
in nonpersonal costs make up 77.2% of the
budget. Of this, $21.2 million,
or 89.6% is budgeted
for services and $2.4 million, or 10.4%,
is budgeted for supplies.
Next. GSD's fiscal year
22 adopted budget was $41.9 million.
With the fiscal year 2022 budget adjustments,
our projected current General Fund budget is
now $41.6 million. In the General
Fund, we are proposing an FY 2023 expenditure budget
of $42.1 million. As noted on the exhibit,
this includes the adjustments for the opening of the A Leaf Neighborhood
Center and contractual and operational adjustments.
Next,
this graph shows the previous five years budgets compared
to our proposed FY 23 budget.
The increase in the budget from FY 22 to 23
is due to the 3% Hope increase, as well as the additional
budget for operational and maintenance of the new A Leaf
Neighborhood Center. This concludes our presentations. Do you
have any questions, sir? We sure do,
and thanks for the presentation. We'll start off with council member Abby Cayman.
Good morning, Director, and thank you again to you and your entire team.
You all are often behind the scenes, but we can't get anything done if we
don't have the structural integrity to do so.
So thank you all. Director, three quick
questions for you. One, can you provide a quick update to
us? I know we're getting going
on construction for the annex tunnel, things like that, but damages
sustained during Harvey. Where are we in that recovery
process for our buildings right now?
And I'll speak first on City Hall and City Hall annex, which you
see every day. And you've seen some significant improvement
in the City Hall basement.
So I'll start with the tunnel. So the tunnel, if you've
noticed, on the Bagby Street side, there's a lot of digging and corriding
to find the source of the water intrusion into the tunnel.
Once we find that and the tunnel is sealed to
keep the water from intruding, that part of the
Harvey damage will start to be done at
City Hall. We're waiting for a call today from
the ceiling tile contractor, and we're keeping our fingers crossed.
As with everything in the nation, COVID and
the war in Ukraine has put a damper on receiving
materials. We were initially told the ceiling tiles for
the hallway and the mayor's conference room would be about
a twelve to 16 week lead time.
The contractor is waiting on a call. We believe we got that down to three
or four weeks. If that is true, we will be complete
with the basement by the end of June.
Kindle library is another. It's on track to
be finished sometime soon. So we're making
progress. But, again, we did run into delays
with COVID and then the war in Ukraine. No, and I bring that
up especially for the purposes for public knowledge in terms
of we're still working on everything from Harvey,
and it's been slow with Ukraine. And I know you all are working as quickly
as possible, but even on city properties,
we're still dealing with addressing a lot of those challenges. Right.
And we look at municipal courts. We are dealing
with well, not our office, but Finance and Mr.
Costello's group are dealing with FEMA for the funding
to replace municipal courts. And it's five years
later. Back in queue, please.
So you're getting off easy. There are no other questions from council members,
but I would like to state yeah, go ahead.
No one else is in queue. Okay.
Secondly director asking.
I got two more questions. Second Director,
you and your chief of staff and your entire staff,
I know, worked really diligently when an issue came up. And I was hoping
you could share with us the
progress that has been made in terms of healthcare coverage for our security
personnel and just all of the efforts that
you and your team made to make sure that we're doing right
by our security personnel. Sure. And if I can,
I'll tell a little story on how this came about. So,
Council Member Cayman, who talks to the security officers here
on a daily basis, noticed the security officer with
a limp, and they talked about going to see a doctor.
And the security officer told them that she didn't have
medical insurance because it was too high. So the council member contacted
my office, and we looked into it,
and we found a huge discrepancy with the contractor
as far as meeting the requirements for payer play,
and the contractor is good. They met with us, we discussed
the discrepancy. And that was all started in December
by I think it was end of February or March.
We had 199 security officers
on the contract working here at City Hall and
City Hall Annex. Of that 199,
only 33 of them were verified to have any
type of insurance coverage. With the help of the insurance company
and us getting them within compliance,
they moved that up totally with their insurance or any other
type of insurance, up to 162.
So we thank you for bringing it to us, because it also
discovered some discrepancies. We have not only GSD,
but dealings with SPD and Oboe on maintaining
the compliance of Pay or Play, which we're working with those
other departments to make sure the contractors are within
compliance. I appreciate that update.
And again, I credit you and your team for
all of the work that was done on that. I simply asked a question.
But the credit lies with you all and bringing them up finally,
Director, I'm asking every department, due to the financial
constraints that not only Council is facing, but the city as
a whole is facing, what are the needs that
are not currently being met by this budget and what
are the foreseeable needs in the near future. So what
I've noticed in my now almost six years of
sitting in this chair, and it's not just this administration,
but it's past administrations that we talk
about deferred maintenance, and where we are with deferred maintenance,
and we're looking at a deferred maintenance bill of $594,000,000.
And that's huge.
And the only sector we can compare
ourselves with is the private sector. And the private sector
tells us the city should be given or putting X amount of money
into capital improvement and X
amount of millions of dollars into maintenance
and operations. We receive less
than half of what they say we should, but we
do it what we can. But the funding
is needed. Being a retired
policeman, I tell Chief Fender I'm 100%,
if you cut me, I still bleed blue. And I tell Chief Pina wait a
minute, it'll turn red. And I understand those
ladies and gentlemen, the job they do, not many people do
it, and they deserve what you give them. But we can't forget about the
facilities they have to work in.
Our biggest fear this year with the, as I mentioned
earlier about shipments being delayed is that we have
HVAC systems that fail,
that cannot be fixed and have to be replaced.
And then there's an eight to twelve week lead
time to get that equipment here. And then we have to rent
temporary equipment. Well, what we found is when we rent that temporary
equipment for three or four months, we could have bought two
units that we're replacing. So that's what
hamstrings us.
Thank you. I neglected to welcome council
member Mary NAN Hoffman, council member Robert Gallegos, and council member David
Robinson. They are here at the Horseshoe. Next question comes from
council member David Robinson and council member Tiffany D Thomas.
Thank you, Council Member Robinson.
Thank you Chair. Thank you all for your presentation. And I
know the GSD is doing everything you can with
the delays, director, as you mentioned, with the global supply chain,
material shortages, construction schedules, cost inflation,
and the list goes on. I guess there's a bit of a preview.
I know coming up on a TTI committee meeting ahead is
some review of our deferred maintenance on
some of our facilities that are in your portfolio. So this is essentially
extra budgetary question, but something that
I'd like maybe some comment from you about the overall impact
of the delay in the global supply
set of conditions with what we've been
able to do. How you've been able to prioritize the projects you have
and what consequences we as a city may be suffering in
terms of a delay on prioritized projects that you've
had. Some of us have had in our hoped
for list of priorities for your department and the city.
So there was a time here at City Hall
in the recent past where we had air handler units on
the corner of Walker and Bagby because we had an
air handler unit in the basement fail,
and we were given some serious lead time
and we have to think outside the box.
Being former military, I tell my guys,
just because a company says this,
they're not the only people in the United States that make this
stuff. We have to go elsewhere. We have to
use whatever we can to speed the process up. We've been lucky
so far that most of the lead times we've been given,
we've been able to reduce by looking
elsewhere.
The impact to the city that this will
have if we meet run into these
long delays is we pay extra
to keep a building cool or warm. That's going to be our biggest
problem, is HVAC system
failure. We had an FCA done, as you know,
in 2012, which is outdated, and we have a
current one that should be wrapped up hopefully next month.
That's going to give us a new light on where our facilities
stand.
Unfortunately, it's not any better than it was in 2012.
It's a lot worse. Let me say I appreciate
that last comment, especially about HVAC and some of what our buildings
need to do for an upgrade. It's also, in addition to the
costliness of it for our budget, it's also incredibly
expensive from an environmental standpoint. What we're doing to
not upgrade our facilities is one of the biggest
degrees in which we're falling short of some of our climate action
goals and goals to align ourselves with the
resilient. Houston. True. That's one reason why
I went to the administration, asked to start
an energy efficiency section in GSD,
which is one person now, Shelley Carter, who's done an outstanding
job with the I think you're aware of the CICO
loan and the Seco project that we about to kick off,
which is the low hanging fruit of Led lighting
in five facilities to start.
I'll say start to meet those requirements. Thank you,
Chair, and I know we'll get an update of that at the upcoming TTI committee
meeting. So thanks for the view. Thank you, Council Member Robert Gallegos.
Thank you, Chair, and thank you, Director, for the presentation.
I know I'm on my 9th year here on Council, and every year I
do look at the demographic breakdown of the different
departments. I'd like to give you kudos
in regards to the breakdown here on employees in
the department. It reflects our city. But I
would also ask if you can give me a breakdown on the management
of your department as well. I'd like to
review that if at all possible. Okay. Thank you.
Council Member Ed Pollard.
Thank you, Chair, and good morning to everyone. Director, thank you for your
presentation. Thank you to your entire team for all the work that you do.
If you had to put a dollar amount, let's say we could use some ARPA
dollars to go towards deferred maintenance and things that
would dramatically improve the state of our buildings
and maintenance, what would that dollar amount be? A reasonable
number. You said dramatically improve.
Yeah, to dramatically improve.
I'll meet you halfway. 250,000,000.
Thank you. Thank you. There are no
other council members in queue. I have one comment and then a question.
There is no department in the city of Houston that I interact
with and probably many council members interact with on a daily basis.
Your department is phenomenal. And I know a lot of this is under my
friend Eric Alexander, but the
janitors that we have that do the hard work day in and day out
are always there with a smile and a can do spirit.
I miss miss Anna. Can you get it back across the street? Because I
love asking her about her dad and seeing how he's doing.
And John just does a great job. And I remember
when Neil was a security guard and we hired him
at GSD. Neil was the most respectful is the most respectful.
Yes, sir. No, sir, can do. Guy I've ever met.
Positive spirit, works his butt off.
He just exemplifies the employees that
we have in the city of Houston. And there's
a famous saying, fish rots from the head. So when there's a good head,
the rest of the employees will do a good job. And it's because of the
executive staff I'm looking at here. And thanks for
doing everything and doing the hard work.
Those people are a joy to be around. They make my life
better today. It makes me realize how lucky that
I am, personally. And just kudos to
the people that you have in your area that do the tough
jobs day in and day out. I know it's not a sexy job,
but, God, they do fantastic work. So thanks for
those folks. My question is wrapped around deferred maintenance.
What is our deferred maintenance backlog? Now, I know we did that study
a while back. What is the dollar amount? I know you gave a $250,000,000.
Say that again. 594,000,000. Say that again.
594,000,000.
It will increase. The estimate is in
2024. It'll stay pretty flat for next year
or two, but 2024, it will go up to 600
million plus. So when you look at deferred maintenance,
that's a lot of money to put into it. Seems like every day we have
people working on our elevators. But think
big or go home. And I look at the land
that we have that isn't in much use next door to us. Tranquility park.
Is it a good park? Yeah, it's okay. It's not one of the better
ones. I'd love to see us build a new facility over there. Blow up.
Lanier, the building. That's a horrible building.
Horrible this building has its issues,
but it's an art deco building and it probably has a great historical
meaning to it. But the police building now, the horrible building.
I know we looked at something. The old exxon building.
God, this is probably five, six years ago.
Can the record reflect that the chair has appreciated historical
architecture? I'd like to let the chair
reflect that from my architect friend. Thank you.
Richard will appreciate that. But don't you think we need to one
day look at a long term plan and begin that
so we get away from this deferred maintenance and do something with building
a new facility, maybe do a three P. We've had a lot of
conversations wrapped around that. Just your thoughts.
You've been around for many years. There is a plan or
there has been talk to Renovate 611
Walker to do something to do
something different at Tranquility Park. So there is a plan.
It's in the rough stages, but there's talk about
doing exactly that. So do you think
it's an optimistic plan or a realistic or a
pessimistic? No one else is in queue, so I'm going to
do you think we'll get it done because our
deferred maintenance gets bigger and bigger and bigger. That's a tough one because
the deferred maintenance is going to keep climbing,
unfortunately, and the prices are going to keep going up.
So I would
be on the pessimistic side. Pessimistic. Okay, well,
we'll go to public speakers, but I always sort of kid mayor Turner,
I said we have a year and a half. What is your
legacy? Complete communities, things like that. I'd love to see
the Sylvester turn of building right across the street from us,
housing a lot of people that need a new place to be housed.
So I'll keep after them as long as you keep after them. Okay.
Because I think there is a plan. Council member Gallegos thank you,
chair. Actually, there is a master plan for Tranquility Park
at the parks department. Unfortunately, there's no monies
for this master plan. But that was something that I had
seen way back when former director
Turner was the parks director. And it's
a really nice plan. Unfortunately, there's no monies.
But I do agree with you in regards to the fountains as they're at Tranquility
Park, I understand we're going to be trying to repair those once again,
but in my opinion,
I think that's just a lot of money being wasted because they've tried fixing
that several times and they just keep breaking.
So hopefully we can come up with the master plan or something
that will save the city money instead of using it to repair something
that constantly keeps breaking. Thank you. Thank you, council member.
So before we go to public speakers, yesterday, we let public speaking
get a little bit away from us. We'd like all the questions to be directed
to council members. We'll do the best to try and answer them if we need
some input from staff, we'll do that.
But we want the directors to be
focused on council members and public speakers to be focused
on us as well. So with that being said,
I will ask you to exit stage Bright
and we will call on our first public speaker and
that is Sabah Blanding.
And if I can add one thing, GSD, we are looking
outside of the box for funding. We're actually
meeting with Bill Kelly and his staff to see if we can tap into
some of the biden infrastructure bill funding
towards energy efficiency. Just wanted to leave that.
Thank you. And Ms. Blanding, direct the questions to us and
we will field the questions from here. Okay. Good morning.
My name is Saba Blanding. I'm a resident of District
I, so council member Gallegos's district. My question is
what environmental services and asbestos,
lead, mold, soil remediation are you
able to accomplish on your current budget? 17 million seems fairly
low for such an essential safety work for property and environmental
management. What are the comprehensive needs of the city of Houston?
What resources would this department need to expand
to address the full needs of the city?
And what are efforts to make sure these services are addressed equitably across
the city of Houston? We just talked about deferred
maintenance a minute ago. You heard it
heavy. Bill on deferred maintenance. Keeping a building like this
up to speed with environmental friendly issues is really
a tough task. I think the direction that
we should head would be to build a lead
platinum type facility that has all the things
that you would want from an environmental standpoint and then
house various departments. We tried to do that a couple of years ago when
we were in negotiations with the folks who owned
the old Exxon building down the street. But we
had a number of issues with it because of the access
to it underground and having the tunnel system work.
But we don't do a very good job with the
environmental side because of the age of the buildings and the condition of the
buildings. But we should do better. And I think that will come
with our ability to possibly do what council
member Gallegos was talking about and that is to do a
new development that will house various departments within the city.
I don't know if any other council members have any. I'll defer
to my Black Cape architect,
David Robinson, who's in queue right now. Well,
I think you're right. I think there's just lots to be done with
our existing facilities, which is why I wanted to mention to the director
some of those important aspects of deferred maintenance. But I
think this Blanding raises an important point, not only for the
issues already discussed with the cost of the mechanical
systems, the upgrade and the cost of the environment,
but also just the health impacts of all the users.
So those are concerns that layer into
how I believe we should prioritize the facilities and think
about that carefully before we embark on any new programs and
new construction. But I share your feeling, Chair, about Tranquility
Park, and I know there are some plans that are coming forward. I believe the
mayor's got a few on his desk that he's considering about that right now.
That's great. Thank you. Thank you, Ms. Blinding. Next was
Jason Oliver. I don't see Jason today, so we're missing him.
What's that? He's running a little late. He's running late. That's all right.
Lauren Johnson.
Good morning, Ms. Johnson. Hi. Good morning. My name is
Lauren Johnson, and I wanted to ask which specific entities are
receiving the $29 million from the Chapter 380 agreement
and how much each of them are receiving and how
do those get approved? Is it city council that approves those?
Yes, it runs through the Office of Economic Development.
380 agreements are reimbursements for infrastructure
work that the City of Houston does not is
not responsible for within certain developments. And that 380 goes
back towards paying those developments for infrastructure work that should have been taken
on by the City of Houston. I'm sorry.
Go ahead and
debt service. So, like yesterday, we went through our Houston Public Works
presentation. And in that presentation, you can see there's a dotted line
around 380 that also goes back to paying our debt. So our
pay as you go programs and all of our infrastructure programs. So those are all
reimbursements. Correct. Okay. Correct. And many times
the developers don't get to a point where we reimburse them a penny.
And we have many developers like that, but we reimburse them over a period of
time instead of taking the work at that
point in time and spending the monies upfront.
So it's actually a pretty good program that works to our advantage.
Any other council member questions, answers on that? Okay,
thank you. Ms. Johnson. Ms.
Jill Grochell. Good to see you again this morning.
Appreciate you all being here again. On second day, actually, third day.
Thank you for the welcome back. Yes, ma'am. Good morning to you all. I will
say I'm a little disappointed that you
asked the people that gave the budget to
walk out yesterday. It was great to be able to speak with
them and let them know how much
we like what they do, and we're proud of what they do. And so I'm
sad to see them leave. Yesterday, we heard
a community group speak about the needs to address the exposed drainage impacting
their community in the north side of Houston,
the northeast side of Houston. Excuse me. They were directed.
That might be a CIP issue. What can
we do to prioritize these important projects within that department?
Thank you for the question. Council member Abby Cayman. Just as
some background, I know I can only speak to our committee, but we
had been asked as standard procedure for all.
Committees when the directors, after they present,
sometimes public comment, can go on for an extended
period of time and they all need to go back to work.
So I appreciate what you're saying, I just also want to
provide context that it's more so the general rule for
all committees, it's not the exception during the budgetary process.
Understood. So to answer your question, CIP is
a roll in three year process. So every project
we had in fiscal year 22 should be completed
and rolls off. Generally not the case because we have more projects than available
funding. And then 23 rolls on and then we add on the backside,
it'd be fiscal year 27. So we
go fiscal year 23 to 27. So then when we finish the ones on
23, they roll off and we add 28 on board.
So the tough thing about that is that many of us are
on here for just another year and a half and we won't see
the work of our office staff.
And what we did in the CIP, that's going to come up long
after we are here or we disappear.
So it seems to work, but the problem we always have
is it's underfunded and we never do all of the projects.
That was one of the reasons why about six years ago we put in the
council district service fund. So each of us have an allocation of dollars
that we can use towards projects that we think are emergency type projects.
And we all do a really good job of identifying the projects within
our area. We firmly believe nobody knows our district
better than ourselves because we're in them every day.
And I include the at larges as well. I know I joke around a
lot, a little bit tough on you, but you all are always present
at our meetings and always concerned about our area.
But CIP is a tough one because it's underfunded and
we have too many needs and wants to really fully fund it.
But working through council district service funds.
And now with the SWAT program, we have extra millions
going in that and maybe we'll have a different allocation
when we look towards I believe if this budget is based on
no increase on sales tax revenue,
I think we're going to have a significant increase in sales tax revenue because
it's predicated upon the price of goods today. And everybody
who's been in a grocery store or bought anything knows that the price continues
to go up. Thus, unfortunately, our sales tax revenue goes up.
So I think we'll have the ability to create more in fund balance and maybe
use some of that fund balance for exactly what we talked about. Just real
quick, do you believe that the Northeast project
is an emergency? Could that go into the emergency bucket?
So I'll leave that up to council member Jackson to decide what's an emergency in
her area not. But I live in Kingwood and
I've been in District B more times than I've been anywhere because it's near my
house. I go up there quite often. But I
looked at those photos again this morning. It was concerning.
But then again, my area lost 5000 homes
and 500 businesses due to flooding.
And we're trying to make sure that when the next hurricane comes,
we don't get caught in that floodwater again. So we all have those
fears. I'm sure that Council Member Amy Peck
will say the same thing about her district, but Council Member
Abby Cayman, especially Myerland and what we've had to
do there. When you live at or
just a little bit above sea level, you're going to have those types of situations
pop up. And I don't care what you call it, whether you
call it global change or global warming, the tornadoes
are coming more rapidly and the hurricanes have more force to them. So we'll
see. Council member Tiffany Thomas. Thank you. And thank you for participating
in public comments. Really helpful feedback, but just something to consider.
Imagine who we could be as a city if we actually receive flooding dollars from
the Glo, right? Imagine the projects that have
been in queue for cycles that are scheduled but not funded.
Imagine who we could be if the federal infrastructure funds were
a direct allocation to the city versus an application process.
Because if it had not been for Hurricane Harvey in this region, those dollars wouldn't
be available. Right? And so we are missing out on that.
And then working through the federal process to schedule
priority projects in any neighborhood. They're all priority.
Right? Let me say, I am one of those people that I lost
my home during Harvey and so I get it. But I also know how privileged
I am and that we were okay. And I believe that there
were many others that weren't. And that's where my heart goes.
Sure. But here's my point is that we are limited
while also being constrained. We're constrained because we
don't have the support, the funding from the state.
We're working through the process federally. And so what we have as a
local city, we're doing the very best and it's not as fast as we
would like. I have at least five unscheduled funded
projects that have been on the books for a while. So I mean, you're absolutely
correct. But just for the public that's listening. The larger
issue is that Houston has been missing out and we have a serious issue
around flooding and infrastructure because it's not a matter of if
another storm will come, it's when. And it could rain for 30 minutes
in the city and you have two inches of water in your drain, like those
storms are that intense. And so we are trying to keep up with that.
And then also look at the plans that were designed pre
Harvey or right after Harvey. Now looking at our new resiliency
standards. Now looking at the new data and city modeling and
what does it take in terms of drainage. So there's some work we have to
do to make sure that those plans meet those standards, because we
don't want to offer your neighborhood or any neighborhood a project just to
say we did a project. We want to make sure that when we come in
and offer a project that you feel safe knowing that those drains work, those streets
will clear and that you won't be in a danger of losing your home.
And so we have to continue this process of raising
this issue. And thank you for bringing that
information to us and keeping it on our radar. It's very helpful. Thank you.
Council member Tasha Jackson. Thank you,
Mayor Pro TEM, and thank you, Council Member Thomas for that.
Also, as Council Member Thomas said, we have SWAT projects,
but then also we have to think about the revenue cap.
I'm hearing throughout the whole from yesterday, the issue is money.
Where are we getting the money? And what we're talking about right now is the
revenue that the city have, but there is revenue that we could have that
we don't have because of a revenue cap. And so two
caps. Yeah. Even if we just had gotten rid of the city
cap, we would have more resources to do a lot of these projects.
So the flood mitigation projects, we have 14 projects on the
book for District B and working with Harris County
Flood Control to kind of mitigate some of these projects. So projects are moving forward.
It's not moving fast enough. We have some projects on the books from
2011. These are capital improvement projects.
So just know that we need dollars, and the
dollars is out there, but we just need to identify
ways to get it. And removing that revenue cap is one
of the ways that we can get some dollars to do projects that we definitely
need within our neighborhood. So thank you. Thank you for participating, and thanks
again, Ms. Grochell. You're welcome. I see Mr.
Oliver showed up, so if you present your tardy slip to
the principal, we'll allow you. You have your 1 minute.
Good to see you again.
Good morning. Yeah, still morning. Okay.
Been here for a while, so good morning, everyone.
Let's see. So I just came in and I
talked about this a bit yesterday, but I think it falls specifically under
General Services. So the security right.
I tried to use my Harris County enhanced library
card ID to get in, and they told me that I needed either
a state ID or driver's license or passport to get in.
Again, this is something we live in Houston. We have quite a
few people who may not have those forms of ID.
So thinking about who is able to come in here and provide public comment,
somebody behind me yesterday had forgotten his license
and was having trouble getting in a staffer once a Council
Member Jackson staffers had to come down and vouch for him. Right. So we
really need to kind of make sure that this is more accessible in that way.
I forgot my other thing. Capital improvement projects.
I just think translation is a big deal,
especially for city documents, thinking about how can we improve the infrastructure
on budgetary documents and then capital improvement documents,
because these affect the entire city. So I just want to make sure and kind
of urge that as well. Sure. Council member Robert Gallegos.
Thank you, Chair. Thank you for that explanation.
When you were saying that you tried to get in with the new Harris County
ID, they didn't accept it. No, I tried it yesterday
on the first floor and then today in the basement.
I'm glad you brought that to my attention because I've met with Mayor Turner to
see if we will accept the new
Harris County ID. And I think that would be a
great, great asset, hopefully.
Can you tell me if that ID has a chip on it?
I don't think it has a chip. Yeah,
it just has the card and then photo
address and then gender and right.
Because I know the sheriff's department accepts it. I know Mayor Turner is looking
at HPD to see if HPD will accept it. And I'm hoping
that this is something that can be used for metro,
something that can be used for the B cycle stations.
Basically a universal Harris County ID that Harris
County residents can use. So thank you for bringing that to
my attention. I'm hoping the mayor's administration is
listening to this as well. Thank you. Thank you. Council Member Abby Cayman
I also wanted to echo my appreciation for flagging the issue and Council Member Gallegos
for the update and taking the charge, especially given
the implementation of the state's photo ID laws,
the additional hurdles that go into place right. That make
it that much harder for an average person to get that state
issued driver's license or photo ID will be
critical to make sure that we're being as inclusive as possible within the parameters
of security and safety that we have to provide at the city.
Right. Thank you. Council member Robert Gallegos.
Thank you, council Member Kayman. Yes. This is an ID that I think can be
used for homeless individuals that need an ID
for individuals that are coming out of jail that don't have
an ID. So that way, hopefully, they can find a job and what have you.
So this is something that I'm hoping we
can work with the Harris County and have it as a universal
ID for Harris County residents or who lose them in floods that
are so rare in Houston and Harris County. Right,
right. Thank you, Ronnie. On that note,
this concludes our General Service Department budget
workshop. We will now transition to to Parks and Recreation.
I see those folks are here so we'll allow a
couple of minute transition and we'll get right into it a little bit early,
which we couldn't say at all yesterday.